hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to leave I finally
found out what I was supposed to do even
though it was probably pretty obvious um
actually you know what I found out in
the you know what I have no excuse
everyone just rest is steward in their
own content nough stood and you are you
are smarter than me
I'm the big dumb okay so by pressing
these buttons in the order that you find
that's what you do you don't look at
this symbol if I could would you know
what let's do it okay so the first was a
heart that was the one up here at the
house the other one was the I already
pressed the first one um press that one
and the next one was to the moon which
is over here and then sine was over here
and then I don't know what that is but I
know that the green one is in hand I
don't need to write this down the green
one was at the bottom uh you know I
don't know and oh the green one was at
the bottom and the clock one was in the
bottom right I don't know what that last
one is I haven't seen anything like that
boy by process of elimination there are
only a few chances or choices only one
of them doesn't have anything what what
did I just press I pressed a Sun one
thumb up to that dang ass thing clocks
at the bottom right there for that one
would be one heart moon Sun right wait a
minute on the right that said that that
was that loan Apple is that an apple
it's red it's red like the okay I'm
gonna
yeah the more I'm looking at that
doesn't look like a clock that looks
like an apple that's an apple the green
ones at the bottom then what was the one
on the laughs bottom what was the mouth
the mouth was red oh you know what so um
Our Lives there's a punishment of this
house gonna ok pressed all his top ones
press that one the only ones left at
this one this one this one any no this
one's a green one this is something but
I don't know what this is the Apple I
was gonna say well who was it bear with
me Jesus
ok here these two are reserved the blue
one can only be this in or listen right
right oh I had a 50/50 shot and I blew
it
ok you know what but now I know you know
what now I know now I know no I know
just yeah you know what you know if this
hurts Mahlon ok here we go and now the
next one's a green one and then the red
apple
ok alright God D I almost had it on the
first try and was headed on the first
try - God dingus this game always I
always feel like I'm gonna be smart and
then all this then it gets taken away
from me whatever you know what it don't
matters this is a toy box good hi Gary
this is the toy box it's rather big well
they had rich parents and everything so
but at any rate hey that's my line it
said there was a key in here I can't see
say I see the bottom is there really a
key in there I wonder
oh oh oh
what happened did she kill us or did she
push us in woah oh my
this doesn't look good you don't have
your red rose and Gary's not here
mannequins looking this way why is there
something over there wait this way is in
this way or what way
smiling blue doll while I'm blue oh oh
all right
mannequins looking one way this way
petals on the ground mannequins over
there yeah let me know if I was wrong my
leg look dumb this is disturbing
oh there's Gary I barely even noticed
him oof Oh hit my head leave are you
okay I'm fine
are you okay ah that's good
at any rate hey that's my line this
place is full of scribbles this is the
toy box we fell in from the upper floor
after she pushed it well let's look out
for a key and get out you look kind of
pale are you really okay what you lost
your rose that's not good at all let's
find it quick okay how why what do we do
about that okay so oh my hello hello oh
wait there we go
found a red rose hey zero fuzz around I
don't know I can barely see anything
petals all over the place by Owens the
ebiz aw everyone knows that I can't find
a facade to save my life oh how am I
supposed to be able to find anything
it's all covered in scribble Scrabble oh
that clown I just noticed as I said
ah how am I supposed to be able to find
anything seriously though this is
baloney is malarkey is malarkey belani
this is redonkulous
it's just pedals everywhere and nothing
else why want from me what do you want
from me I don't know where a vase is
what do you want from me game seriously
what do you want from me what do you
want from me what do you want from oh
there god that was almost impossible to
see
oh good lordy
oh boy
these guys he'd be careful oh my god oh
wow
what the hell jeez
back off there sonny jim Mary you gonna
get it did this room change uh yes there
seem to be a lot more yellow roses
thorns blocked away telling us not to go
up and inspect them thorns are odd they
don't seem real they don't feel as
lively as plants should very much fake
of course there's lots of lots here that
doesn't feel real that's sunlight for
example we're really in this deep now
aren't we
well thorns would be a bad idea and
probably would Kelly burn it is that a
good idea
oh yeah okay what about going out no oh
okay all right then fine Oh bird you
we're good just rum this isn't the toy
box is it more importantly see with that
EEB the painting on the far wall I think
I've seen it before let's take a look oh
oh
who's there Oh Eve Gary you're both okay
how did you get into this room leave now
don't take another step
we'll leave right now oh now no move it
ah got me oh really
just like that I guess I don't want to
resort to burning it I mean if there's
any sort of redemption for this
character I feel like you should have
some sort of never mind you know what
never mind
let's do
let's just burn these down okay you know
what you know what you know what okay
yeah okay you know what you know I'm
nope nope tough tough tough tough tough
dude
ah got you now
tear it down yes I gotta burn it Oh
whoosh oh my oh my
No Oh
she's just sported I have to stay girls
sure can't be scary Oh Gary ding that's
why everyone loves Gary sitcom like huh
well anyway it burned up a lot more
violently than I expected you okay that
glass shattered after all huh you seem
fine I'm glad we're wolf okay let's get
going okay I don't know what else was I
supposed to do
I like the visitors coming though this
is her diary probably uh I really don't
think that there's how to make friends
well ah all right a bit late I don't
even know if that was the right choice
but I I don't know it seemed like the
only option I didn't see another option
did you know well there you go then vine
be that way
what did that do oh I got a pinkie
that's right that's right
I remember now let's go it's back to the
reality real whoa it's dark watch your
step IVA
Oh watch your face come on tell me what
to do
go punch you in the balls
Hey
wait a minute oh I'm back in the
beginning maybe maybe yeah yeah huh
it's yeah so uh so what about that
Oh what about that
this is the painting that I looked at
first it started at all
ah what's this big mural fabricated
world hey isn't that the former gallery
does that mean if we jump into this
we'll be back there but how are we meant
to jump into a painting bla oh my huh
Eve look the frame now might be our
chance oh wow
yes Summerlee and hurry up Beebe EEB he
what's wrong come on
oh he bi finally found you
she shows looking everywhere don't just
go running off places on your own
father's waiting for you to D let's go
EEP EEP what are you doing hurry up and
come over
EEP how many times have I told you don't
go following strangers hey it's not
scary okay you'll be fine
NIEM listen to your mother you'll go
with some stranger you want to never see
your father and mother again people pull
you over come with me
grab my hand Abe ah I'm pretty sure that
carries the right choice pretty sure hi
preacher I'm pretty sure unless he's
been fooling me this entire time maybe
maybe you can't remember what you were
doing really huh don't you know what you
were doing hey uh hi have you seen any
diabolical entities something strange
happening in this place
anything at all anything at all No
hold on there miss you can't combined
here well if you say so where's my mum
and dad was my mama and my dad ah Gary
Gary Gary hmm what is it little lady
what's this statue ah this is called
embodiment of spirit apparently when I
look at this sculpture I feel somehow
sorrowful I wonder why I'm sorry if I
said anything to trouble you
never mind what I said well bye no Gary
no there you are Eve Oh were you looking
at this wow this is really great it
represents a person's heart I supposed I
wonder if you have such a beautiful rose
in your heart II let's take a look
around have you looked at anything else
I hope we find some more things you like
and memories crannies what does that
mean what does that mean what I mean by
memories crannies what about my crannies
are you gonna be talking about the
crannies man leave my Queenie's out of
this
what
not on do that
Oh save clear dad oh I thought it clear
save data all right slide dyslexic
and the earlier what was that even the
best inning I gotta go look this up hang
on you guys I'm on a bull this this part
ends okay hang on let me just move all
right so um my playthrough my first
playthrough went to the end but stay
right there I'm gonna go look some up
and see what the hell happened okay okay
all right what the hell okay
gonna gonna go
I'm guessing jumping through that
painting might have I don't know I don't
know shut up mom I need to I'm gonna be
right back okay guys um I got I think
the second to best ending what what
happened was I didn't have a Gary
friendship store of overrate what how
was I able to know I don't even know how
you get that I think by talking to him
some people were saying like nerd lilies
are you carrying him Howard eyeball - no
I did good you know what I'm gonna chalk
that down as a victory in my book I'm
writing that down write it down right
now
victory for the markiplier there we go
my handwriting everybody that's the end
of this story I did good
I did good enough and if you didn't
think I did good enough on my first
frickin playthrough completely blind
with no other choices well then you are
a lovely person with a personal opinion
and I don't l with anything against you
but if you dare to say that I don't do
nothing good well in your perfectly
entitled that opinion and I am now gonna
have argue with you at all though how
about that
huh you'll weaken I ain't gonna go get
you are still in a good ending yoga